this is michael fuller
in 2004 he became britain's first and
only black chief constable
but to get there face battles no other
chief constable had to fight
despite the warnings michael persevered
and in 1975
after being brought up in care he left
to join the metropolitan police as a
cadet
everybody said there's no way you do
that then my biological parents said you
don't do that
my friends and school friends said no
way do you do that even my teachers i
mean everybody i looked up to said don't
join the police that's just not the
thing for a black person to do
in 1981
racial tensions led to violence in many
inner cities
and michael would find himself on a bus
in the middle of a fight between black
and blue
there was this quite sinister atmosphere
outside where there were black hues who
came to the side of the bus and started
taunting the police officers on the bus
and the police officers on the bus were
all white
and generally a lot older than me
but very bitter and twisted i felt and
used racist exclusives
one one of the issues was about
belonging that i didn't belong to the
people
uh the the group and the tribe on the
bus and i didn't feel like
i belonged to the tribe outside the bus
i didn't want to make an issue of it
quite the opposite i was not going to
let my color actually hinder me both in
terms of being promoted
and in terms of really
ensuring that i had a fulfilling career
he was successful setting up the racial
and violence crime task force in
response to the death of stephen
lawrence and as a commander spearheading
operation trident massively reducing gun
violence and black and black crime
but the racism would still continue
even when i was very senior i didn't
mean i escaped the racism
from even junior staff
but now he would have the power and says
this is why representation is still key
in terms of the things i'd like to see
improvements on i'd like to see
increased representation at the senior
levels of the police there haven't been
any other black chief constables
appointed since i was appointed as a
chief constable of a provincial police
force we need increased representation
at junior levels as well
because there's um
fewer black
people actually joining the police
than there are from other ethnic
minority groups
michael's journey was a long and hard
one but after becoming one of britain's
highest ranking officers he has taken
his place in history
shiman freeman powell sky news